another massive week in Washington some
truly blockbuster news I mean you can
tell just how earth-shattering was from
the shocked reactions
I was shocking it really is shocking I
really believe that this is an issue
about a fight for our democracy that
sounds like a bombshell
tell me more this is the my most
disturbing day in Congress the most
disturbing thing I've heard well that's
hard to say the most disturbing thing
I've heard cos so many things I've heard
over the past several weeks are
disturbing I think we're agreed
it's disturbing so what the hell
happened last week was there a financial
crash no actually the stock market hit a
record high did the economy tip into a
recession
no that has steady growth and highest
employment in history was there some
kind of terror attack
not really Oh apart from the one where
we took out the head of Isis so what is
it what is this crisis I think it's
supposed to have something to do with
national security it's about national
security putting our national security
at risk what we're dealing with here is
corruption abuse of power in a way that
damaged American national security it's
about national security okay we get it
it's about national security but what we
turned to the one person who is smart
and sharp enough to explain this
dangerous national security threat in a
crisp and clear way the idea that
someone would invite a foreign power
into our election and in the process
withhold apparently the allegation from
some within the administration who heard
the conversations withhold vital aid
military aid voted for by the Congress
while Ukrainians are dying in the dom
boss that is the eastern ukraine in
order to take on russians who are there
still killing them killing these people
is just i it is it's one of the things
that no president that i'm aware has
ever ever thought i'm doing wake up he's
finished man
that does sound really bad
no president ever thought of we halt
withholding military aid to Ukraine that
Congress had approved except wait wasn't
there I think there was one president
who did that who was it again
I remember it was this guy that's okay
you can't expect Joe to remember it was
years ago but it's not just Joe Biden
who's conveniently forgetting it's all
the Democrats and all the bureaucrats -
all on their high horse about Trump
damaging our national security by not
sending proper military aid to Ukraine
even though he did actually send it and
Obama didn't this is nothing to do with
national security it's all just an
illusion the bombshell revelations so
shocking so disturbing that the
Democrats and ruling class state TV got
so excited about last week told us
nothing we didn't already know the truth
about this impeachment is that it's not
about finding out things we didn't know
it's about telling a story a highly
partisan political story and they've
settled on their cast of characters
Sunland Sunland Sandlin Sandlin Taylor
Taylor Taylor Taylor Taylor Ivanovich
fenman many women have in min Binh Minh
Minh Minh fiona hill fiona hill fiona
hill fiona hill Sandlin Soglin Saarland
Sandlin yeah but now they tree
ivanovitch Taylor Taylor Taylor George
Kent Georg Cantor orange cat Georg
Cantor Georg kid the anti-trump cult now
recite the names of these career
bureaucrats like holy incantations
Taylor vim and Fiona Hill oh please as
we keep reminding you this is just the
system striking back against a president
whose agenda on trade on immigration and
in this case on America's role in the
world
they arrogantly oppose I've worked at
the heart of government
I've run policy processes of all kinds
these permanent bureaucrats hate
political back channels because it takes
away from their power to control policy
they use every trick in the book to
brand political involvement as
illegitimate but they're the ones who
are acting illegitimately they have no
legitimate mandate
except the one given to them by the
people who are democratically elected
and accountable in this whole story
there's only one person who fits that
description and it's President Trump and
remember these snooty civil servants
that ruling class state TV is putting on
a pedestal they're part of a smug
arrogant elite that's been wrong on
every major issue for the last 30 years
I'd rather take advice from the chickens
in my backyard than Washington's foreign
policy establishment there are my
chickens by the way they're very smart
that's me with them this morning they're
very cute they're very smart chickens
but there was one name missing from the
partisan impeachment fanatics cast of
characters last week this man kurt
volker he was there just like the others
giving hours of testimony the transcript
of his evidence was released last week
just like the others but not a peep out
of ruling class state TV about volca I
wonder why Oh could it be because as I
pointed out weeks ago when I read his
witness statement Volker exonerates the
president on the main impeachment
charges this week I read the transcript
the volcker transcript on page 36 Volker
states clearly there was no linkage
between policy and investigations on
page 41 he explains that it was the
advisors to President Trump not the
president who cooked up the idea of
getting the Ukrainians to make a
statement about investigating 2016 and
the Biden's in order to get President
Trump to view the new Ukrainian
president more favorably page 47
according to Volcker it was the
Ukrainians who wanted to be connected to
Rudy Giuliani
page 79 Volcker says that military aid
was held up for a number of different
reasons on and on it goes
page after page 360 pages exonerating
the president but somehow despite being
one of their precious career diplomats
ruling class state TV barely mentioned
Kurt Volkers testimony last week and the
Democrats haven't invited him to their
public hearings next week you'll saw
those people the president Trump's rally
wearing read the transcript t-shirts as
in read the transcript of the
president's call
you can add to that read the volca
transcript it shows that this whole part
is an impeachment is a farce of course
no normal person cares about any of this
we're really in the weeds when we're
banding about the names of obscure
bureaucrats and diplomats no one's ever
heard of but you know we promise to
bring you the truth about impeachment
every Sunday night for as long as this
lunacy goes on so there you have it all
right tell me what you think of that
that's Steve Hilton X and at next Rev
FNC